c'est la hausse annoncée des taux
d'intérêt face à l'inflation qui fait
craindre comme ça une récession est ce
que c'est la bonne chose à faire
d'augmenter comme ça les taux d'intérêt
comme on nous le promet depuis quelques
temps avec nous ce soir joël leclerc qui
est professeur d'économie et de finance
aux buffalos state college dans l'état
de new york madame leclerc bonsoir
est ce que les banques centrales ont la
bonne approche en augmentant et en
promettant d'augmenter les taux
d'intérêt pour faire baisser l'inflation
selon vous
[Musique]
mais sur ce qu'il faut prendre en
considération seydoux vient l'inflation
qui augmente les taux d'intérêts
d'affaires a baissé toute l'économie en
jean d'une récession
engendre un manque de production dans
les secteurs dans tous les secteurs mais
on voit que des problèmes dans certains
secteurs en particulier qui ont été
vraiment touchée par la crevette piles
par la guerre en ukraine alors il ya
différentes façons qu'on pourrait
peut-être s'attaquer directement ces
secteurs qui sont touchés où on voit
vraiment menaçants et puis sa serviette
une meilleure réponse
allez place en couvrant seulement mais
mais quand on parle d'augmenter les taux
d'intérêt longs parle d'un demi point de
pourcentage certains évoquaient trois
quart de point de pourcentage des
hausses agressive à la banque du canada
la réserve fédérale vous en pensez quoi
de cette de cette possibilité de ce que
ça peut faire
mais moi je suis tout à fait contre les
augmentations du taux d'intérêt pour
essayer de redresser l'idée de
l'inflation en ce moment parce que
l'inflation vient pas d'une augmentation
de la demande ça pue seulement elles
viennent vraiment plus de des déblocages
la chaîne de production elle vient aussi
de la spéculation dans les marchés pour
les matières premières qui dans le
secteur pétrolier à cause de la guerre
en ukraine et à cause de la chine alors
vraiment si on pourrait s'attaquer
directement à ces éléments l'on pourrait
résoudre d'inflation augmenté les taux
d'intérêts maintenant ça va vraiment
produire les façons ce que ça va faire
c'est pas juste faire en sorte qu'on va
avoir une augmentation du taux de
chômage aurait à voir une augmentation
des prix pour les gens vont avoir plus
de difficultés à s'acheter des maisons
parce que les hypothèques 28,1 mais
jean-marc le sedif critères à s'acheter
des voitures parce que les voitures un
pêcheur
alors vraiment là on va créer des
problèmes c'est qu'on n'a pas de
problèmes qui ont la source et la tour
et la source donc c'est les problèmes
dans l'est dans les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
mais la source c'est aussi la politique
zéro coved en chine c'est aussi la
guerre en ukraine la hausse des taux
s'attaque à la demande il ya un problème
du côté de l'offre alors quelles sont
les solutions plausibles selon vous
dans tant de parents ce qu'on faisait
c'est qu'on ait manqué le taux d'intérêt
mais maintenant c'est plus je pense
qu'on puisse développer de nouveaux
outils par exemple si on voit que les
prix dans la du du lait ou des yeux ou
du pain des choses que les gens
utilisent tous les jours ci s'y plient
au segment petit que le gouvernement
peut donner des subventions aux
compagnies canadiennes américain qui
produisent ces choses là pour remplacer
les les productions produisons par la
chine l'autre chose qu'on pourrait aussi
faire c'est ptet comme commencé à
vraiment changé ne me demande si on
demande beaucoup beaucoup
d'essence dès qu'on peut commencer à
changer une demande qui met plus de
d'emphase sur l'énergie verte et pour
l'environnement s'est transformé dans
une énergie états unis dans un secteur
vers l'énergie d'heure alors vraiment si
chose nous devons améliorer la situation
de l'inflation s'en mêle à toute
l'économie en récession ça vaut et d'une
position à long terme en plus oui avec
moi je pense au noble energy en un temps
les cas pas maintenant de vraiment se
développer dans ces danses et façon
d'avoir des outils de développer les
outils qui nous faut pied c'est ce qu'on
devrait faire
mais en même temps on aime le clair si
on a un taux de chômage qui est très
faible aux états unis comme au canada
une croissance économique qui
relativement fort ça va mieux que
justement dans le temps de nos parents
comme vous dites dans les années
soixante dix où dans les années
est ce que vraiment une hausse marquée
des taux d'intérêt
risque vraiment de créer une récession
oui absolument ça fait maintenant c'est
les gens ont des emplois
on a une augmentation de la demande les
gens de tout va bien mais là aussi on a
deux on risque en augmentant les taux
d'intérêt d'abord et pour l'intérêt
élevé qui ont été créés encore plus
d'inflation qui produisent le problème
de l'inflation créances à faire en sorte
aussi que certaines entreprises qui sont
moins efficaces les plus petites
entreprises qui prennent des prêts pour
les capable de créer des emplois créés
depuis indices devises ces entreprises
ont failli conquérir le taux d'intérêt
augmentent ça fait que ça va créer du
chômage lanvaux s'y trouve est petit
dans une situation semblable à ce qu'on
a vu dans les années 70 on est rentrés
décrit cette situation auquel on a taclé
directement la cause de l'inflation ont
pour éviter ce tout à fait autre que
c'est possible
pardon c'est pas simple pour les
citoyens parce que les marchés plongent
en même temps on a une chute de
pratiquement 20 % l'on parle d'un bear
market le pouvoir d'achat qui diminue de
plus en plus les prix immobiliers qui
sont très élevés comment comment doivent
réagir les citoyens face à tout cela
et je pense que les citoyens doivent
premièrement cette stratégie ils doivent
essayer de se battre pour avoir des
salaires plus élevés pour que leur
salaire augmente en même temps que
l'inflation augmente parce que les
salaires réels ont en fait depuis les
derniers 30 ans et son fils qui se
réduit d'année en année qu'il a avec
l'inflation qui augmente c'est comme une
chute incroyable du salaire réel des
gens à tous les jours ça c'est des
choses qui sont vraiment importants il a
su protéger dans les marchés boursiers
ben non c'est les gens qui ont envie de
ce 27e il faut qu'ils continuent à
travailler
mais seulement de la patience
madame leclerc merci beaucoup c'est très
intéressant vos propos ce soir merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne i r d
[Musique]